so far this year more than 14 000
migrants have arrived in the uk in small
boats today both candidates vying for
the leadership of their party and the
country have been setting out their
plans to try and stop them there is
absolutely nothing racist about wanting
britain to have secure borders that work
talking tough in a new campaign video
today the former chancellor out pulling
points in cheshire told party members
the system is broken for too long people
have felt that our borders are not
secure enough i voted for brexit in part
to have control of our borders and i now
want to deliver on that is a priority
for me it's a priority for the country
and as prime minister i will apply the
same grip and determination to that as i
did to getting this country through
kovid
the foreign secretary wasn't out
campaigning today herself but supporters
say she's determined to do whatever it
takes to tackle the issue
it's about focusing on what the public
are saying to us and they're concerned
that people are entering illegally and
that we need to well be sensitive
but we need to be get be firm and robust
in his 10-point plan rishi sunak vowed
to tighten the definition of who
qualifies for asylum as well as creating
an annual cap on the number of refugees
accepted this trust meanwhile pledged to
create a strengthened bill of rights to
reinforce a legal basis for tackling the
issue mrs sunak says foreign countries
access to aid trade and visas should be
made dependent on accepting the return
of failed asylum seekers mistrust says
she'll increase border force numbers by
20
and will look again at controversial
plans to force boats to turn back in the
channel both candidates are wholehearted
in their support of the plan to send
asylum seekers to rwanda and have
pledged to pursue deals with other
countries too so far no flights have
actually taken off due to legal
challenges with 120 million pounds
already paid out said to be lost if the
high court rules the policy unlawful
charities argue is unethical
well whoever becomes our next prime
minister really does need to rethink our
whole approach to refugees and asylum
because the last few months we've seen
an approach that's really impractical
but also deeply inhumane
while both candidates argue over the
legality and viability of each other's
proposals both know they need to have a
plan to tackle an issue of key
importance to both party members and the
country at large as every day the
numbers attempting the dangerous
crossing continue to rise i'm andre
acast sky news